[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales nous sommes le
lundi 23 mai au sommaire aujourd'hui
focus dans ce journal sur la nomination
de yale brawn pv en tant que ministre
des outre mer la composition du nouveau
gouvernement a été dévoilée vendredi 20
mai le premier conseil des ministres
s'est tenu ce lundi matin l'occasion
d'établir les priorités du quinquennat
toujours en politique à la proche du
premier tour des élections législatives
nous faisons le point sur les enjeux du
scrutin à venir dans les yvelines focus
aujourd'hui sur la 7e circonscription
et puis le festival de cannes se déroule
jusqu'au 28 mai à cette occasion
instagram organiser une créateur villa
du 19 au 20 mai dernier elle a réuni des
centaines d'influenceurs au palais
bulles objectif rendre assez accessible
les coulisses de l'événement
[Musique]
et avant de développer ce journal à
l'occasion de son premier déplacement
dans le département des yvelines pap
ndiaye ministre de l'éducation nationale
s'est rendu au collège du bois d'aulne à
conflans sainte honorine établissement
où enseigne et samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire-géographie assassiné en
octobre 2020 il lui avait déjà rendu
hommage pendant son discours lors de la
cérémonie de passation pouvoir
et je vous le disais en titre a le
premier conseil des ministres s'est tenu
ce lundi matin l'occasion pour le
nouveau gouvernement d'elisabeth bornes
de se pencher sur les priorités à parmi
les sujets abordés le pouvoir d'achat
mais aussi l'éducation à la santé et
l'écologie la liste de son nouveau
gouvernement a été dévoilée ce vendredi
20 mai parmi les nommés yale brunch iv
pour le ministère d outre-mer député de
la 5e circonscription des yvelines
depuis 2010 est candidate à sa
réélection également conseillère
municipale de la ville du vésinet depuis
2020 la cérémonie de passation de
pouvoir avec sébastien lecornu a eu lieu
vendredi depuis l'hôtel de montmorin à
paris nous avons eu sa réaction rendu
vendredi après l annonce de sa
nomination écoutez c'est est au micro de
grégory canale
je la bonne réaction de joie
j'ai le parcours de quelques uns de la
société civile qui s'est engagé en
politique avec tout son coeur et tout
cela met toute son énergie et le
parcours que j'ai il récompensé
aujourd'hui et puis surtout à une
immense responsabilité
parce que les outre mer hachée chez
c'est la france en grand et donc avoir
en charge
cette ce domaine de l'action de l'état
c'est c'est quelque chose d'exaltant de
passionnant et et en même temps une très
grande responsabilité je sais que nos
compatriotes attendent beaucoup donc
voilà je suis déjà présent en conscient
de la charge qui va m'apporter et bruno
corps et des teams mère du vésinet vous
êtes avec nous bonsoir bonsoir et du
coup on le disait il ya une brouille
privé et dont conseillère municipale au
sein de votre mairie déjà votre réaction
face à ces nominations vendredi
qu'il y ait le moins de bébés depuis
apprécie tant et cette vie cependant
extrêmement
sont informatives on l'a dit elle et
puis aussi sur les conséquences qui t'a
crise sanitaire pour nos concitoyennes à
coutras marin voilà est donc l actif pas
dit sur le trail où l'ex
commission des lois sur des territoires
donc ça c'est bon on n'a absolument plus
tu
logo ministre maintenant il faut pas que
tu es tu débutes nicipal de binaires et
donc ils travaillent rémois qui n'oublie
pas sa ville qui est sur le terrain qui
a des actions de proximité
qui est très impliqué là
avec l'ensemble des coins des citoyens
et beaucoup de communication beaucoup d'
écoute il ya beaucoup de blogs beaucoup
de loyauté
et fiers de leur côté dans d'autres
municipalités se sont donc les qualités
qu'elle peut apporter j'imagine au
gouvernement absolument et donc donc
cesser de ton de loyauté son travail son
dialogue permanent à présent ça et on
l'a vu encore une fois sans oublier la
demie de l'an dompter les résidents et
avec les nombreuses d'actions qu'elle
m'aide localement y compris dans un
domaine qui sont des tubes comme paris
coin essayez donc ménager dans le cas de
la loi 3ds daloa où ses rues pour
contester et le cas avec donc on est
dans un an dans une activité une
activité hostile qu'un local que
national et international maintenant on
est content qu'elle va amener dans le
nôtre gouvernement à la première minute
au public et à tous les français dans ce
domaine là donc fierté de travailler
avec elle au quotidien
merci beaucoup bruno cooren était
d'avoir été avec nous et je le rappelle
vous êtes le maire du vésinet merci
beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
un nouveau rôle donc pour l'ancien
député de la 5e circonscription des
yvelines on vient de le voir et elle a
suscité de nombreuses réactions je
propose de découvrir ce compte rendu par
bixente malien santesteban
de l'émotion lors de la passation de
pouvoir avec l'ancien ministre au poste
sébastien lecornu pressenti un temps à
la justice c'est finalement aux autres
merck l'ancien député yale brawn pie v a
pris ses fonctions je remercie emmanuel
macron elisabeth bornes pour leur
confiance je consacrerai toute mon
énergie à la mission qu'ils m'ont confié
j'agirai pour chacun de nos autres
maires avec une indéfectible ambitions
on est tous dans les yvelines très fière
d'elle est très satisfait de sa
nomination c'est une amie à ses proches
qui a fait un excellent travail qui a
déjà été élu meilleur député l'année
2002 21 je suis présent pourriels
d'abord parce que c'est une amine parce
qu'elle a eu ou souvenirs et des
oppositions des débuts très difficiles
comme président de la commission des
lois elle n'a rien lâché elle a fini
comme une excellente présidente de la
commission des lois et ça il fallait un
sacré caractère pour tenir parce que on
lui a pas fait de cadeau nommé dans un
ministère qualifié de difficile en
raison des crises sociales économiques
et écologiques que traverse les
territoires ultramarins il ya elle brode
piv et bénéficie de la confiance de ses
homologues politique c'est une personne
qui en plus de d'excellentes qualités
relationnelles c'est ce qu'il faut
saluer rend tout
était accompagné
sébastien lecornu qui était le précédent
unis d outre-mer en nouvelle calédonie
par exemple pour préparer le référendum
qui s'est tenu en fin d'année dernière
elle a également mené à l'automne une
mission d'évaluation de l'application
des politiques
dans dans les antilles d'autres messages
d'encouragement ont été adressées à la
nouvelle ministre ancienne présidente de
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
d'abord son ancien vice-président
stéphane mazars mes plus sincères voeux
de réussite à yaël brawn qui fait que
j'ai accompagné pendant cinq ans comme
vice-président et qui entre aujourd'hui
au gouvernement nous avions partagé deux
voyages en outre-mer pendant ce
quinquennat mais aussi des députés
d'outre-mer toutes mes félicitations aux
nouveaux membres du gouvernent en
particulier à notre nouvelle ministre
des outre mer et elle brûle privé je
connais ta capacité de travail et d
coûte ainsi que ton intérêt pour nos
territoires premier dossier sur les
cales jan groen pie v se penchera la
crise sanitaire et le statut de la
nouvelle calédonie un travail de court
terme d'abord ne connaissant pas sa
longévité au poste selon les résultats
du parti présidentiel aux futures
élections législatives
et puis parmi les autres nommés elle
aussi a assisté ce lundi à son premier
conseil des ministres et sylvie
retailleau et la nouvelle ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche a sur twitter elle s'est dite
honorée de ses nouvelles responsabilités
formation recherche et innovation seront
au coeur de sa feuille de route bonsoir
grégory canal et sur youtube merci
d'être avec nous donc jusqu'ici
président de l'université paris 5 listes
c'est une véritable universitaire qui a
été donc nommé on l'a dit à la tête du
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
les maths et les sciences c'est son truc
c'est ce qu'a dit elle le figaro
étudiant à propos de sylvie retailleau
et effectivement sylvie retailleau 57
ans affiche une longue carrière
universitaire passé par l'école normale
supérieure de cachan qui est devenu
aujourd'hui le n s paris saclay elle
obtient l'agrégation de physique
appliquée en 1988 en 1992 la niçoise
d'origine devient un docteur en sciences
à l'université paris-sud sylvie
retailleau poursuit sa carrière en tant
que chercheuse puis professeur toujours
à l'université paris sud avant de
devenir et doyenne de la faculté des
sciences et en 2016 la physicienne est
élue présidente de l'université
paris-sud l'université paris 11 1 plus
précisément elle a été fondu depuis 2020
dans la grande université paris saclay
dont états dont elle est à la tête
depuis deux ans c'est un établissement
auquel est rattachée à saint quentin en
yvelines pour l'heure en tant que
membres associés l'université versailles
saint quentin et son président alain
buis qui ont donc beaucoup collaboré
avec sylvie retailleau sa nomination
comme ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche est une
bonne nouvelle sur plusieurs points de
vue c'est une excellente nouvelle à moi
je me réjouis évidemment c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour elle mais
surtout pour l'enseignement supérieur et
la recherche
sylvie retailleau et quelqu'un qui
maîtrise les dossiers qui
à une connaissance très fine des enjeux
de la recherche de la formation et des
priorités elle a pris différents
graduellement différentes
responsabilités elle a été directrice de
l'ufr des sciences d'orsay qui est un
poste très important et puis jusqu'à lui
dire c'est pareil sud et la caution de
paris-saclay donc les différentes étapes
ça nous permet d'avoir une vision
complet du monde de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
au sein de nos universités
et donc grégory sylvie retailleau va
pouvoir s'appuyer finalement sur cette
expérience à la tête de l'université
paris saclay qui est la première
université de france la 13e rang mondial
d'après le dernier classement de
shanghaï qui datent de 2021 elle n'est
en 2020 l'université compte 48 mille
étudiants neuf mille chercheurs 275
laboratoire elle est composée de quatre
grandes écoles dix composantes
universitaires deux universités membres
associés et dont lui vs cus cet
organisme de recherche
le projet de ce nouveau modèle
d'université à la française a été mise
aujourd'hui sur de bons rails par sylvie
retailleau qui pourra profiter de son
expérience et de ses compétences dans
ses nouvelles fonctions de ministre je
crois que c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
rigoureux
qui a une force et une capacité de
travail exceptionnelle
elle est aussi une très bonne
négociatrice donc très fort tant en
concertation mais est avec eux peut-être
la différence elle a aussi des qualités
humaines qui sont incontestables et donc
qu'elles sont un peu les dossiers chauds
et bien il ya une inquiétude sociale en
ce moment parmi le monde étudiant avec
une précarité qui a explosé durant la
crise sanitaire du colis 19 40% des
jeunes ayant quitté le foyer parental
vivraient sous le seuil de pauvreté le
gouvernement prévoit sur ce point une
réforme du système des bourses et des de
l'aide personnalisée au logement autre
dossier c'est la loi de programmation de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche entre 5 et 10 milliards
d'euros dont les présidents d'université
attendent beaucoup j'attends
ce qu'on attend d'une mini donc c'est
déjà la mise en oeuvre de la loi fin la
poursuite de la mise en oeuvre de la loi
de la programmation et de la recherche
évidemment
mais peut-être plus largement l'enjeu
sur les moyens à l'allocation des moyens
qu'on va donner aux établissements
l'enseignement supérieur et je crois que
là il ya une très forte attente de
l'ensemble de la communauté
universitaire est maintenant en poste au
ministère sylvie retailleau devrait
remettre sa démission de président de
l'université paris saclay dans les
prochaines heures de nouvelles élections
auront donc lieu au sein de l'université
merci beaucoup grégory canal et
rédacteur en chef de télé 78 hadj
rédacteur en chef adjointe à fait exact
est
[Musique]
toujours en politique un petit point sur
l'histoire a à présent notamment la
place des femmes en politique est la
france est l'un des derniers pays
d'europe à avoir autorisé le droit de
vote des femmes en 1944 d'une manière
générale les femmes sont largement
absentes du tableau politique jusqu'au
gouvernement a de valéry giscard
d'estaing en 1974
pourquoi autant de temps pour intégrer
les femmes à la politique je vous
propose d'écouter armel le bras chopard
professeur de sciences politiques elle
était l'invité ce matin de patrice
carmouze il ya eu tout un débat au cours
de la troisième république où on a
refusé le droit de vote enfin le sénat a
refusé le droit de vote aux femmes sous
différents prétextes elle allait semer
la zizanie elle allait importer le sexe
dans l'assemblée
tourner la tête des hommes qui ne
pourrait plus faire les lois comme si
elle était dans la forme il faisait pas
elle même aussi c'est un argument qu'on
retrouve en
1945 quand l'école de la magistrature et
créer
les magistrats disent mais c'est pas
possible elles vont remporter le sexe
dans le prétoire on va plus pouvoir
juger
sereinement et alors ils ont glissé à ce
moment là ils se disent eh ben on l'aimé
on va faire quelque chose elles ne
pourront être que
magistrat dans le parc elle ne peut pas
être magistrat du siège évidemment ça
n'a pas pu passer c'était étaient hors
la loi oui pourrait pas faire une loi
pour dire en plus les arguments c'est
que
la femme elle est toujours un peu
fofolle les hystériques bref il ya une
nature de la femme et la nature de la
femme c'est ça qu'il faut choyer on
parlait tout à l'heure des nominations
des ministres tout comme yell brunch iv
d'autres yvelinois ont été nommés
ministres retour sur ceux qui ont marqué
les gouvernements précédents avec célia
400 go
[Musique]
la première ministre elisabeth bornes
vient de faire entrer niveler noises au
gouvernement mais ce n'est pas la
première fois que cela arrive mahdia et
faisait ses cartons il ya une semaine
nommé ministre délégué en charge de la
ville le 6 juillet 2020 elle avait été
élu député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines en 2010 cet attrape sa ville de
naissance autres trappistes à rentrer au
gouvernement en 2012 sous la présidence
de françois hollande benoît hamon
devient ministre de l'économie sociale
et solidaire il est élu dans le même
temps député ps de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines mais doit
renoncer à son mandat en intégrant le
gouvernement en 2014 il est nommé
ministre de l'éducation nationale un
poste occupé environ quatre mois
puisqu'il décide de démissionner en août
2014 en désaccord avec les choix
politiques de françois hollande sous la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy et
plusieurs personnalités ville sont
devenus ministres comme valérie pécresse
elle devient en 2007 ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche puis ministre du budget des
comptes publics et de la réforme de
l'état christine boutin député des
yvelines entre 1986 et 2007 rentre
également dans le gouvernement fillon en
2007 en tant que ministre du logement
élu député ump des yvelines de la 12e
circonscription en 2009 david douillet
sacré plusieurs fois champion du monde
de judo est nommé ministre des sports en
2011 président actuel du sénat et ancien
maire de rambouillet gérard larcher a
été ministre délégué aux relations du
travail en 2004 sous le gouvernement de
jean pierre raffarin autres yvelinois
devenu secrétaire d'état chargé des
programmes immobiliers de la justice en
2002 pierre bédier actuel président du
département un peu plus loin dans le
temps michel rocard devient premier
ministre de françois mitterrand en juin
1988 il avait été élu député des
yvelines en 1969 en bas dans l'ex
premier ministre sortant maurice couve
de murville derniers premiers ministres
sous la présidence de charles de gaulle
et on reste en politique avec les
élections législatives qui approche les
yvelinois sont appelés aux urnes pour
élire leurs représentants de leur
circonscription à l'assemblée nationale
ça se passera les 12 et 19 juin à la
rédaction de tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir
plus clair nous faisons le point sur les
enjeux du scrutin à venir dont les
yvelines focus aujourd'hui sur la 7e
circonscription
mathilde franck où vous êtes avec nous
bon soir à lens a alors quelles sont les
communes concernées déjà alors cette
circonscription justin l elle est située
au nord du département elle regroupe les
villes comme chanteloup-les-vignes
conflans sainte honorine triel sur seine
ou encore andresy et vernouillet cela
représente 150 mille yvelinois environ 7
7e circonscription penche plutôt vers le
centre droit de plus plusieurs années en
effet depuis 2010 est c'est la députée
michèle de vaucouleurs membre du modem
qui la dirige cependant cette dernière
ne se représente pas elle laisse sa
place à nadia et l'ancien briscard au
vendée globe à la lumière par faut juste
avant le nadia et était député pour la
11e circonscription attrape sa ville de
naissance cette dernière fait
aujourd'hui campagne dans la 7e
circonscription pour ensemble la
nouvelle confédération issus de trois
partis politiques pour la république en
marche alors est-ce qu'elle marche en
terrain conquis sans faire deux mauvais
jeux de mots oui et non car si la grande
majorité des communes a voté pour
emmanuel macron au premier tour de la
présidentielle
les villes comme chanteloup ou melon ont
préféré donner leur voix à jean luc
mélenchon
c'est donc dans ces villes que nadia et
devra essayer de convaincre les
habitants et de regagner leur confiance
et donc parmi d autres candidats qui on
retrouve finalement et bien huit
candidats au total se disputent cette 7e
circonscription justin il ya une parité
exemplaire puisque ces quatre femmes
contre quatre hommes pour la gauche
c'est michel christophoul qui
représentera la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et solidaire alias lannux
seul membre du parti socialiste désigné
sur les douze circonscription des
yvelines elle pourrait faire basculer la
septième à gauche en s'appuyant sur les
votes acquis par la france dans soumises
notamment dans les communes de meulan et
de chanteloup les vignes pour la droite
c'est le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent bros
qui se porte candidat nombre des
républicains ce dernier avait été élu
dès le premier tour des municipales dans
sa ville cet avocat bien connu dans la
7e circonscription pourrait également se
voir propulser à l'assemblée nationale
du côté de l'extrême droite emmanuel
fortin sera la candidate pour le
rassemblement national et christelle
tidjane de reconquête parmi les autres
candidats frédéric janvier sans
étiquette politique son programme est
constitué des idées venant de droite
comme de gauche le conseiller municipal
d'opposition de conflans sainte honorine
ali kaya repart pour une troisième fois
sous la bannière de lutte ouvrière part
dont pierre plancoulaine fait campagne
pour le parti animalistes et rémy
vincent pour le parti pirate parfait
merci beaucoup matip de franck ou
d'avoir été avec le journaliste pour tv
[Musique]
et après cette longue page politique un
peu de culture le festival de cannes se
déroule jusqu'au 28 mai radio sensations
en partenariat avec tv 78 vous fait
vivre l'événement de l'intérieur ou en
allant à la rencontre des réalisateurs
acteurs et producteurs de la région
comment tu as alonso vous emmène
aujourd'hui à la découverte de la
créateur villa s'est organisée par
instagram en marge de la grande fête du
cinéma il ya rencontré un influenceur
aux franciliens regarder à l'occasion du
festival de cannes instagram réunit
plusieurs de ses créateurs et pour
organiser cela ils ont choisi le palais
bulles la célèbre villa du couturier
pierre cardin pendant deux jours on
célébrera les talents français et
internationaux d'instagram et on
retrouve quelques franciliens
[Musique]
parmi eux le parisien même ce 24 ans
connue pour ses proches il réunit 1813
mille personnes sur tik tok 518 milles
sur youtube les 206 milles sur instagram
comment est ce que tu es tombé nam ce
toit dans les réseaux sociaux comment tu
as trouvé ton concept pour percer sur
instagram je suis tombé du troisième
étage
comment comment est ce que je suis tombé
bas je kiffe les proc depuis que
celui-ci en fait avec mes potes et où on
se faisait plein de projets du coup bah
je me suis dit tiens tu vas faire un pro
claque que tu vas post est carrément sur
internet et au final j'en ai mis un puis
deux ça a bien marché et aujourd'hui tu
es invité à la créateur villa
d'instagram aux marches du festival de
cannes nice est magnifique c'est un truc
super grand il ya un an - je sais pas
combien d'endroits exactement il doit en
avoir 20 je crois c'est très très coloré
très grand très spacieux objectif est
qu'ils exécutent un endroit tu as aimé
particulièrement ouais
on y va
[Musique]
knox 42 % des 18-24 ans ont envie de se
lancer dans une carrière digitales sur
les réseaux sociaux on a tous des amis
qui ont envie de percer sur instagram
moi aussi j'en ai quelques-uns qu'elles
seraient des conseils que tu pourrais
leur donner qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui pour percer sur la zone
franchement le conseil numéro un les
gars c'est avant tout qui fait ce que
vous faites vraiment amusez vous parce
que si tu chantes souk où tu te forces
massa va se voir et la vidéo ne sera pas
en même temps aussi chaud qu'au dessus
tu organises on va dire tu vois ce genre
de manière à ce que tu poses
régulièrement est fou et approcher en
jambes ras le bol des gens qui suis-je
ont commencé un chat bleu au cloud et
c'est comme ça qu'on va avec le temps le
maintenant qu'on a fait le plein de
conseils pour poster du contenu digital
on attend vos publications avec
impatience un du sport maintenant action
flamme olympique c'était un relais à
vélo organisée par le collectif vélos
ile de france c'était ce samedi 21 mai
l'événement était de passage donc dont
les yvelines l'objectif demandé un
réseau de pistes cyclables pour
desservir les sites retenus pour les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques à de
paris 2024 au programme deux relais dont
un départ d'elancourt et un de
seine-saint-denis l'arrivée était à
paris est le relais yvelinois est passé
notamment par la colline d'elancourt le
vélodrome de sky et même le château de
versailles
et puis toujours en culture ils étaient
5 encore en lice pour la première place
ce samedi 21 mai sennour qui a remporté
la onzième saison de the voice la jeune
mauricienne de 16 ans devient la plus
jeune gagnante de l'émission adultes
elle avait déjà participé à l'émission
the voice kid en 2019 pour la sixième
édition c'était à l'âge de 13 ans elle
cette année est entrée dans la
compétition elle est entrée dans la
compétition en chantant tous les cris
les sos à 2 daniel balavoine aux
auditions à l'aveuglé elle avait choisi
elle de rejoindre l'équipe de florent
pagny patrick jacq de disney est allé à
leur rencontre de maurepas siens et
maurepas viennent pour connaître leurs
réactions ça permet de montrer qu'il ya
du talent partout peu importe peu
importe la ville et et au contraire
c'est très bien normalement je m'appelle
nous
quelle coïncidence mais j'aimais
beaucoup cette émission de juliette est
pas toujours toujours mais je l'aimé
bien lourd parce que moi je viens
d'arriver ici je pensais pas qu'il y
avait des talents dans le coin ça fait
graver les heures de savoir ça même
andré devrait si elle est intéressée
pour faire du petit caux la bourrache
moi je suis mort en tout cas ça fait
graver plaisir et puis j'espère qu'à
coach leurs efforts dans ce sens bah moi
je dis que je suis fier d'elle parce que
j'ai regardé franchement elle assuré bah
c'est bien ça représente la ville donc
c'est bien ça fait connaître un peu la
vie mérite d'avoir gagné c'est une fille
bien les gentils ça se voit et est super
bien nour est également très soutenue
par la mairie qui avait dit poser des
affiches dans la ville pour l'encourager
dans son aventure écoutez la réaction du
maire c'était au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude bas des gens la
féliciter c'est une vraie fierté pour
mort palais maure passe bien et pour
nous requinque remarquable parcours on
lui fait aussi beaucoup une belle
carrière puisque aujourd'hui débute une
carrière professionnelle je crois
qu'elle a signé un contrat déjà avec
universal music et elle nous avait
chanté chômeuse gones de queen avec une
superbe démonstration vocale elle avait
ébloui toute la salle en présence du
président du sénat d'ailleurs et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis dans un instant
retrouvez votre magazine sportif ce sera
avec michael elle me doré puis et
bixente mais rien senti steban pour vos
résultats du week-end très bonne soirée
à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]